We got some sh some, some dates coming up and all that going on. Hollywood,
California, and wiser, or Hollywood, California. When, I mean, I'm sorry.
It's not hot. Well, I will be in Hollywood, California, but I mean, Hollywood,
uh, Florida, wiser of Hollywood, Florida, when there's a Hollywood, California,
it's so highly confusing. There should only be a Hollywood,
California or Hollywood, Florida, because Hollywood is such a specific name.
Here we are with Jeremy Renner, main attraction, chin. He's a singer too.
Here we go with one of the Avengers, main attraction by Jeremy Renner.
Jeremy ran her looks like a most regular guy world.
And that's why people like him. Cause he's still accessible. Jeremy Renner,
main attraction. Jeremy Renner is a really good actor.
He's actually so good,
but people don't realize it because he's got such regular face. Here we go.
Jeremy Renner, main street, main attraction there. We got about it.
Ever since that movie directed by that girl
hurt rocker hurt, hurt rocker,
not hurt rocker because it's not about grandma. It's not about a grandma with,
with plantar fasciitis. It's about the war. So it's not hurt.
Rocker heads hurt locker. Here we go. Live Jeremy Renner manufactured.
Here we go. He sings too. For some reason, he's not just an Avenger.
He's not just a good dramatic actor.
He also sing songs you would listen to in a dentist office. Here we go.
Jeremy Renner, main attraction.
He's gotten definitely gonna have songs about flying and flying so high,
pretty soon, coming out with a song. That's a guarantee you,
Jeremy Renner will have a song that's called flying too high or something like
that because it would be in an elevator or Jeremy Renner,
Romanian made attraction. Bulls-eye,
there's a joke in there somewhere.
I'm not going to do it because he's a Hawkeye bullseye. Here we go.
Jeremy Renner manufacturers. It's got regular faces. So good.
Um, so yeah, so, uh, but yeah. So what the?
So what was I even doing saying Jeremy Renner, dude, killing it, man.
He just made a song. He made some songs. Did you know that he dude,
the fact that, let me just go,
let me just start this by saying I straight up think Jeremy Renner is a
phenomenal actor and I love Jeremy Renner and I think he's a great he's.
He seems like such a good guy. He's a great actor.
I love him in the movies. I want to be his best friend. I'm a Jeremy Renner fan.
And the fact that he's doing also rock music is
hilarious, dude. It's awesome.
His also the fact that he can just make rock,
like he can do any kind of music. He can do any kind of music.
He can make singer songwriter. He could do stuff. That's really like cool.
Like dark like tool. He could do anything he wants to do,
but he chose straight up rock. Oh,
that's so funny to me, dude, with his short hair, he just chose rock.
And that's hilarious, man, with.
His rag face, dude, that makes me.
We laugh, dude. And he has a song called main attraction.
Ah, dude, Jeremy ran a rips.
He's my favorite.
Now that he does rock music. Did you know that if he comes to LA,
I'm going to go do, I'm going to go to a show as a fan.
I'm not asking for any extra perks I'm paying for the ticket.
I'm standing in the back, dude. It's going to be so dope.
I'm not hitting on my agents. Sometimes they hit on my agent.
Could you get tickets for me to go to Nope, not this time. Dude.
Buying tickets for the Jeremy Renner show,
standing in the back and he in popcorn.
Dude, his song.
First of all, of course the music video starts with this, the beeps, you know,
And he's walking into the, he's got a long coat.
The fact that it starts with
the fact that it starts like this.
Oh man, dude. Oh,
and he's walking in the desert.
He's got a long coat. Oh.
The way it starts.
[inaudible] dude, he's going like this.
He's walking down the road. He's going like this.
I thought today I have to do this. I have to talk about,
I have to do the podcast and I can't burn bridges with Jeremy Renner.
I got to meet him though, bro. I got to do this.
If you don't.
Let me tell you something, dude, if you don't like this song, main attraction,
you're a aide or dude it's designed to make you feel good.
I'm not gonna play the whole thing because of the little flag it,
but it's so dope, dude. What is he?
You know, you know dude.
Oh and the comments dude.
Not one comment.
Not about Avengers.
Oh dude.
The best it's got 4.3 million views.
It says, this is what Hawk I did during those last five years.
Here's another one. What about Thor off world?
Dr. Strange on available captain Marvel.
Don't invoke her name Hawkeye. You wouldn't believe me. If I tell you.
[Inaudible].
Hawkeye you wouldn't it. If I tell you,
Do you know what he should honestly be in the Hawkeye outfit in this music
video, just ripping fans with
what do you call it prior?
And then someone just goes for,
and they just get ripped through a thing with a Hawkeye arrow and they
die and they literally die and they die. Still rocking out like.
[Inaudible].
They died literally like this with a, with a, with a, with an arrow like this.
And they're just, this is how they die.
They're doing this and they go like this. They go like this. Oh dude, Germany.
Oh what the
[inaudible] will be the best. That would be the best.
I'm sorry, but that price.
Now look at here we go. 95% comments of vendors,
Hawkeye 3% comments, Spanish, 2% comments like the song.
That's what this guy tweeted or a YouTube comment. Okay.
So let me get this straight.
This is the one I didn't get because let me get this straight.
He's an actor singer and a makeup artist. Wow. Huh?
Thor off world. Captain Marvel. Unavailable Hawkeye on tour.
That's what this guy says.
Oh man, this guy wrote that on camera.
He killing it with bow strings off camera. He killing it with guitar strings.
Definitely a 14 year old guy. Right?
Some of these are great though.
Where's the one where the there's always the comment where that's like how much,
yada, yada, do you want to rock Jeremy Renner? Yes. Where's that one?
Definitely. I like that. That's the main YouTube comment.
I want to jump off a bridge. When I see it.
How much do you want to rock Jeremy Renner. Yes. Or whatever it is. And I'll,
I'll find it. I guarantee it's in here. Here we go. Producer.
How much epicness do you want in this song? Jeremy Renner. Yes.
Oh dude. Yar a dark
[inaudible].
Dude. How much dorkiness do you want in this comment? Yes.
[Inaudible].
Is hilarious. No, I no know I'm a, now.
I'm a gnome and now I'm a Noma now. No.
What's the I can't play.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[inaudible] yeah.
Wow.
You know, he had the meeting. I was like, I want to rock Jimmy.
This is what Jimmy writer did when he came into the thing. W whatever,
whatever music thing he's doing,
he comes in and he sits down in that long coat with his hair. How it always is.
Jeremy Renner is so interesting. The only actor never,
absolutely ever changes his hair, no matter what part he's doing, dude.
And he goes, and he sits down and he, and they, and they, and his wife,
universal, BMG, whatever the it is, you know, whatever, whatever thing he goes.
And he sits down and he walks in and what, by the way, he walks in like that.
He walks in like that with his arms out.
And he has got the long coat and then he sits in the chair and they say,
so Jeremy Renner, where are we here? You want to do music? We're all for it.
What kind of music do you want to make? And he goes like,
he literally goes like this. He says, he, no,
what he does is there's a toothpick in his mouth because he's a bad, of course.
And he goes like this.
Uh.
And he said, what's so funny. And they say,
you asked me what style of music I'd like to make. And the guy says, well, yeah,
why is that funny? And he says, because the answer is obvious.
And then he puts on sunglasses and then takes them off and says, I want to rock.
Okay.
And they go like this. Yeah. We know it. And then it goes,
I'm gone, man. Where's the car, man. I know valet. He doesn't like that.
And then gives a valet guy, $2.
Dude. He gives.
A guy, he gives a valet dude, Jim inner the guy, well, you got $2.
And the guy thinks, did he make $40 million on Hawkeye?
And then he goes like this. And he goes like this. He literally goes, he says,
Hey, he goes like this. And he, and he, and it's so racist. She says,
this is Eduardo. And the guy says, Oh my God. Yes. And he says, Hey.
And he gives him $2 and he goes, don't spend it all in one place.
And then drives away.
And then, and.
Then way down the road, you think he think, but you can't tell.
Cause he doesn't say it loud enough. He says I'm Hawkeye.
Oh. I'll do a duet with him. I'll do a duet with him.
You understand me? A God Jeremy Renner, this,
dude. He gets no hate. He's so good. Nobody hates him.
He makes the killer song. And what? There's another song too.
Oh, he has another song called heaven. Don't have a name. Huh?
You said the name before it didn't have a name.
Haven't don't have a name said heaven in the title.
Chris.
It doesn't have a name. Didn't you? Oh, no. I'm sorry. Nevermind. Just uh,
it's all good. Just nevermind. Just.
Oh, I love it dude.
Because you're the star of the show, man. I'm talking about me.
See cruelly. Oh,
Oh. Is always the same hair. Can't tell if I'm 35 and 50 Brown.
Oh,
Thanos loved his voice. That's why he was spared from the snap.
14.
It says, I found out he w by the way,
who found out that Jeremy Renner sings because of the Jeep commercial.
Yeah. Sad. White.
Widest thing in the world is finding out Jeremy Renner sings while
watching a Jeep commercial. That's the widest thing in the world.
Because all white guys, when they saw that music video, they went like this. Oh.
That's what they did. They said, Oh, Jimmy render sings.
Okay.
That's the widest thing. The only thing wider is liking an escape room.
That's the only thing wider, Dude.
If you were in an escape room, if they shut the thing and they were like,
if they, if you were in an escape room and they were like, Hey guys,
Good luck getting out more ha clink. And they will.
We gotta get out. We got one minute.
No, it's a stupid job.
It's just so awesome that he sings main attraction.
And he's also got a song called nomad.
Oh.
So cool. The fact that he could do any music and he's like, Hey, are you crazy?
I want a rock.
You know, a gentlemen is a kind of guy who bites his lower lip when he.
Cause he thinks it's sexy, dude. And I do that too. So that's all good.
Me and Jeremy Renner are a pouch. We're pals. We're pals.
We're the main attraction.
Wow.
I want it.
I saw him at the car wash once and he looked like he was such a good dad.
Hey kid, we need you for distraction. Spider-Man okay. I'll do it. Hawkeye.
Hold my bow. Oh God dude.
These dorks online. Hold my book.
Whoa.
Um, anyway, he killed it. Jeremy Renner promised to him,
he should win the Grammy best new artist.
You know what Jeremy Renner does for sure. When he goes to Las Vegas,
he goes and he bets and he literally sits at the table
and lets the house win for a bunch for a long time.
For like I'm talking to two hours and 15 minutes,
he lets the house win and he's losing money, dude.
I'm talking about parts of his paycheck. Okay.
And then he says, well I guess, I guess today's just not my luck.
That's not my day. And then it gets up and turns around and goes to leave tips.
The lady, a chunk and the lady's like, God, he's tipping. Nice.
He lost.
Close to a million dollars and he's tipping.
And then he says, after he's turned around, he says.
You know what, let me just play one more time.
And he Cassius,
some chips plays a bigger bet than he's ever played
more than he lost. And then he gets 13
and the lady has, is showing an, uh,
showing the face card and he, and she says,
you want to hit? And he says, you know what? The way I've been playing is so up.
I might as well play against the rules. Now I'm going to stay.
And everyone goes, Jeremy Renner, main attraction,
Mrs. Singer did, you know, there's some Jeep commercials. And they say,
you really shouldn't. And Jeremy Renner says, I got this.
And then she says, okay.
And then she flips the card over and it's a six. And then everyone goes,
Oh, and she has to hit.
And she flips a car over and it's another face car and your face card.
And Jeremy Renner says, Hey, I'd like that massage.
[Inaudible].
And then he walks away with his chips and he comes out of wet.
And you notice as he's walking into the elevator,
nobody noticed until the last moment that his Dick was out the whole time.
[Inaudible].
Do you understand? That's the, my dream world.
Not for me to do it. I want Jeremy Renner to do it and I want to see it.
I'd start beating the out of everyone. If I saw that out of,
out of respect and I'd be punching the, everybody, and people would be like,
what are you doing? I'd be like, just in case Jeremy winter.
Doesn't like any of these guys, I got them all. Yeah, dude. That's the life.
That's the life in my head.